and then everyone on the Internet is
like what kind of person has a pizza
party with their friend at three in the
morning yeah except for two gay dudes
are trying to suck each other and then
yeah me too me too
owning it we all bought it
[Music]
who here watched the Paul Pelosi video I
did I didn't even thank you for sharing
it I loved it because we talked about
that when it happened yeah and there was
no body cam footage at the time so we
only we're gonna go ahead and watch the
video the video's [__] up dude
I definitely don't want all of you what
do you think
he definitely doesn't want olive oil oh
yeah
he's more of a coconut oil kind of guy
he's like painting the frames of the
windows huh got the painters tape on
you just said the N word
um
[Laughter]
holy [__]
everything's good nothing or see here
officer drop the hammer nope hey he said
nope going on
oh my what's up
why did it do that dude that video is so
crazy he's nuts [__] it's crazy a cop
told them to drop the hammer and he
whacked them with it yeah no he said
nope and he started watching the cop
goes what's going on over here he's like
everything's good
everything's fine here meanwhile he's in
his [__] underwear and stuff like
that and he's like one hand's on the
hammer and he's looking at the cop and
then the other dude David the paper
whatever is you can see it in his
[__] eyes like drop down he's like
nope yeah he said nope
yeah and you guys see also the
surveillance footage from the back of
the house as well no okay so basically
there's a there's a surveillance camera
from the back of the Pelosi's house as
well David uh depeb he like first walks
over uh behind the house and you see it
in black and white and then he comes
back later a couple minutes later with a
backpack puts his backpack down pulls
out a [__] hammer and stuff like that
and just starts breaking the door the
handle the door to break in
that's how he broke into the house who
is he and how is he related to Paul
Pelosi he's not related he's just like a
crazy guy that that's like into politics
and wanted to question Nancy but she
wasn't home she said he wanted to break
her kneecaps or some [__] yeah it's like
it's like a bunch of crazy guy talk but
then basically they said the reason the
security was low is because when Nancy's
not home then the detail is lesser and
the cops are they part of surveillance
or that someone Falls uh the cool thing
is he called the cops and because the
guy was with him when he was making the
call he had to ask for the help in a
weird code way that like um he was like
hey I got a friend here like so people
were speculating oh they're friends uh
no it's like the guy was with him when
he was making the call so we had to try
to not uh he tried to not like hey I
want to order pizza
with the pizza really fast please it was
basically something like that and the
cops just kind of knew and then everyone
on the Internet is like he what kind of
person has a pizza party with their
friend at three in the morning yeah
except for two gay dudes are trying to
suck each other's dicks off and then
yeah me too me too
owning it we all thought it well that's
one of the narratives that was going out
it was like why is that guy one in his
underwear they're gay lovers because
because the The Narrative started with
them meeting at a at a gay club in San
Francisco wait where is that from it's
not made up no that's where that's where
the narrative start is because oh it's
because Nancy Pelosi is out of town and
that he met like uh Paul Pelosi
apparently goes and has gay sex rages
like with with guys right in San
Francisco
this is one of his this is one of his
boyfriends right and then and they could
do better they had a drug field they had
a drug-fueled like sex Fest and it went
wrong that was that was one of the
stories at the time yeah those were the
best stories powerful imagine [__]
waking up after getting decked with a
hammer and like oh my god did they catch
the guy and it's like um
they're all saying that you were 69ing
each other here's the thing everyone
thinks you're gay that's nobody the
doctor wakes you up it's like hey good
news you're okay bad news is
[Music]
don't read it here's what made me think
that the idea of him being gay was sus
because have you seen Auntie Pelosi's
[__] big old titties
my God she aged well below the neck it
couldn't be gay if you're at home with
those things I'll say that the dumbest
thing was when this was a breaking news
both sides of politics were trying to
brand that guy as right wing or left
wing depending on who's saying it they
were like look at his background he's
the right winger because of this and
that and then they found out that he was
like involved in all this left-wing
events well I remember one of the one of
the biggest pieces of evidences is like
they went to his house and they had a
flag and it was like a gay flag or
something yep there he is he's gay even
ball pelosiers [__] each other and
I'm over here with you guys like yeah
dude that guy is totally funny me too I
was like this guy is not only gay but
but apparently he commits assault yeah
yeah this guy's nuts but then there is
footage of him like walking up the
neighborhood and stuff like yeah so it
wasn't like a setup meeting point like
that's kind of a dumb way to meet up up
with a secret gay lover I do have to say
though the cops handled this like [__]
yeah seriously because like all this is
floating around all they had to do is
release this [__] yeah right like like I
don't I again I don't understand how
that protocol is like maybe Bart's
friend does but like if all this is
swirling and you're trying to get out
ahead of it wouldn't you try to do a
better job of helping people to
understand what the [__] actually
happened out of there yeah what would be
in your mind a reason for not showing
this kind of footage uh
early on to save their apps I'm not
showing it yeah I don't know what what
goes on with court proceedings and [__]
like I wonder why it took so stuff gets
held up longer yeah but like even for
um like Paul Pelosi like why wouldn't
you just like release the footage so
people know what's up versus like let's
have months of speculation that I'm gay
if people are out there saying I'm gay
I'm gonna get ahead of this thing
I'm going to the news tomorrow and like
we're gonna show the body can't finish
no no no I like the rumors
I'm French kissing my wife like me and
Nikki are making out on the camera and
I'm like I'm gonna see what a gay man do
that
look at me squeezing on titties here
maybe maybe it's a little bit of a maybe
there's a bait tactic of like hey let's
let's make everybody slander the [__]
out of me for a while and then I'll call
in those lawsuits forget about the
Google stuff am I right Nancy's like hey
there's too much heat on us for this
insider trading can you stay gay for a
couple more months not a bad well like
if you kind of think about it if we want
to talk about it the story of her making
how many millions I was like 300 million
dollars of her dumping a bunch of Google
stock or whatever I don't know if that's
true or not well she's also not speaker
anymore so that's what a lot of people
are like oh it's because of this
incident and all that remember that Meme
that says like imagine having a law
named after you for so you can't Insider
trade and you never did any time for
doing the actual trading but dude now
now that we know this and now that I
have my narrative blow it apart and [__]
like I'm thinking like is Paul Pelosi a
master [__] Trader like maybe like
maybe there's footage like body cam
footage of Paul Post being like I gotta
I don't know I don't like the Fibonacci
chart on this [__]
I think uh we're gonna dump Google here
babe and then Nancy blows is like I
don't know you do whatever you do yeah
yeah that's what I hope it's a
coincidence he's just a master he's just
chilling out there with Michael Bernie
and [__] is that like best friends he's
like look at the RSI is this [__]
massively oversold I'm getting now
maybe he's always looking at Berkshire
Hathaway like I told Warren he never
listens to me he's a master I know their
trades were way better than [__] more
buffers they beat Wall Street they beat
everybody Pelosi capital is [__]
crushing it maybe it wasn't the cop
saying drop the hammer it was Pelosi
saying I'm gonna drop Arm and Hammer
Telegraph
y like Paul Pelosi other than the fact
that he's just in his boxers he's like
holding a drink the whole time yeah so
he's like holding a drink and holding a
hammer while this guy's like and it's
like hey but it makes it seem so much
more casual than it needs to be the
crazy thing is that's kind of he played
it right when you have like a crazy guy
in your house and you know he's like
nuts yeah you kind of can't do the
normal yeah home protection [__] versus
in that moment when it's like the cops
are there [__] it and the guy's trying
to take the [__] Hammer like I don't
know like chucking the drink in his face
or some [__] and try you know you know
when they open the door it seemed like
two brothers who were caught Fighting by
the parents
do anything like when you hear we were
fighting like they still want to fight
but they don't want a rat and [__] [__]
[__] the way the the cops open up the
door and they see a guy that's supposed
to be an intruder with a a hammer in his
hand are they supposed to react
differently
like did they handle that situation well
I mean the SEC it looked like it took
two seconds to like Drop The Hammer you
know what I mean it looked like they
were already right where they needed to
be with it because I was like because
when I watched that video I'm not a
[__] cop so I would [__] know but
like when you watch that video in your
head you're like could have that hammer
hit been avoided you know not that close
proximity to the victim yeah it's like
it's like this hostage situation thing
they don't just take the shot yeah yeah
are they supposed to oh they're trying
they might be processing too like why
don't they have pets
yeah because it's such a weird situation
but yeah because it's like what do you
first notice you know yeah that's true
plus like they knocked on the door and
then some someone opened it said okay
yeah yeah yeah but the funny thing is
can you drop the hammer nope you would
think that if he was actually in like an
aggressive situation and like people
knocked on the door like is the culprit
gonna be like yeah go ahead and open it
yeah yeah oh it's the cops open up yeah
there's a hammer on it in hand the guy's
crazy yeah he's nuts yeah he's like off
and if Pelosi was able to get on the
phone and actually like talk to the cops
while he was there the guy's like
there's some kind of weird thing because
I'm sure he was just yelling at him the
whole time so maybe they are lovers yeah
yeah I would love it I would love it get
into the scoop right now
there's another one where they believe
he's q a non and then like he became um
pretty deep into that stuff and then his
goal was to go out and assassinate them
chewing on with the rainbow flag yeah
outside so [__] way pretty tough
that's probably the the leftist uh spin
on them and then the right wing spin is
the is the he's the gay uh mistress what
if he wasn't deranged he was just smart
and he knew that this was gonna throw
everyone off dude the crazy thing is
like a skilled assassin probably
wouldn't have played it this good
like he got into the house he's with the
dude he had many chances to take him out
yeah I can't believe they fractured his
skull he actually did get him like I'm
surprised he didn't like get killed like
that was a [__] serious Hammer shot
and he's a big boy he gets knocked out
right away on that it's like boom
[__] he's like snoring and [__] like
that it's like a it's a knockout how
don't they have glass break
um glass brick detectors like on the
Pelosi house bro maybe because they're
busy painting that's the thing that was
weird is they their only answer was that
when Nancy's not there like Security's
way down I thought there'd be at least
one or two people or something which is
not like a game which is weird because
most regular people have more security
than that right
Andrew Tay has more security especially
when you got like 300 million dollars
yeah yeah off one trade Gavin newsom's
kids goes to uh one of our friends
parents school and there's two black
Suburbans that are parked in front of
the school wow running for eight hours
in case [__] happens dude I used to work
with Nancy Pelosi's kid
his name's Andrew
he was at Maker Studios with me he's a
nice guy oh really yeah did he have
security no he was he was all very
casual very chill you ever asked him
about his mom's uh Heavies
um but she didn't have him then oh those
are new they're new new oh no way that's
because well other or she had a good
pantsuit collection for a couple years
she definitely got them things out now
yeah yeah yeah
the timeline coincides with the cardano
boom so I think there's a little
something
she's getting that ADA I didn't know she
was into crypto
foreign
[Music]